[Musique]
on passe à la politique les candidats à
l'élection présidentielle sont en
campagne nathalie arthaud la candidate
de lutte ouvrière tenait son premier
meeting pour sa première campagne hier à
saint denis s'est elle vous le savez
qu'il succède à arlette laguillier son
portrait signé patrick ferrante et
pierre pachoud
début du marathon mi-journée à
aubervilliers en seine-saint-denis
nathalie arthaud quitte le lycée
technique où elle enseigne
l'informatique en gestion
la porte parole de lutte ouvrière à
l'étiquette vu à la télé ces idées
trotsky tu sens moins connus
je les ai entendus entre
à les eaux a expliqué mais oui lutte
ouvrière est les communistes la seule
candidate communiste à la présidentielle
c'est donc ainsi que se revendique
nathalie arthaud qui s'est installé dans
le fauteuil d'arlette laguiller égérie
de lutte ouvrière de 74 à 2008 n'aimait
pas dans l'ehpad arlette d'arlette
laguiller ça je crois que tous ceux qui
seront intéressés et qui m'écouteront se
rendront compte que oui je défends les
mêmes idées mais ni des mêmes look mais
la nouvelle venue revendique sa
différence je m'étais juste fait un
petit morange il n'est ce pas
c'est une photo qui est très récente
l'ignorez vous en route pour son meeting
du jour la candidate anti capitaliste
est servi par l'actualité avec la perte
du triple à part la france j'ai
peut-être d'autres choses à développer
je n'allais pas mis en avant ultimes
révisions de copies alors qu'elle est
attendu avec curiosité par ses
sympathisants
j'ai toujours écouté arlette laguiller
lui et à ne voir sa successeur
moi ce sont mes idées bien sûr je suis
très à gauche par les claviers à la
voilà la us capital de sympathie dans le
les milieux populaires
nathalie arthaud alala gagner gagner en
notoriété c'est l'objectif de sa
candidature d'où la reprise d'un refrain
à succès travail aux travailleurs
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]